welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and the Hulk may have a future in
the MCU after all with new details
coming out about the she-hulk series on
Disney Plus and for once these details
weren't spoiled by Mark Ruffalo saying
too much in an interview wait till you
see this next one everybody to do some
speculation suggests that Stephanie
Beatriz would be a great choice for
she-hulk Jennifer Walters but after
Beatriz shot down the rumor is currently
glow actor Alison Brie is the Walters of
the week but beyond these casting rumors
production details have linked the
precise way she-hulk will connect to the
Hulk as we know him currently in the MCU
and that answer slams the door wide open
or where they could go with the whole
franchise in the future more warning in
case you consider widely available news
spoilers and hearing someone talk about
it ruins your life okay we just learned
that the working title for the she-hulk
series is Libra a reference to the
astrological sign depicted with scales
as a reference to Jennifer Walters
career as an attorney
the casting notice the show is released
seeking its she-hulk actress reads
she-hulk is a lawyer and cousin of Bruce
Banner whose emergency blood transfusion
from Bruce empowers her with hulk-like
abilities so yeah the takeaway here is
that they are adapting the original
origin story for Jennifer Walters who in
the comics is a cousin to Bruce Banner
her legal involvement with a criminal
case leads to her getting shot and
losing a lot of blood but Bruce gives
her a transfusion and his
gamma-irradiated blood transforms her
into the she-hulk which he gets pissed
but jen has more control of her
transformations and unlike banner she
typically stays in she-hulk form
practice in law and fighting alongside
the Avengers and other Marvel heroes the
fact that Marvel Studios is sticking
with this Hulk blood origin as the
explanation for Jenn's powers is
significant because previously the
science of MCU Hulk has been a bit muddy
and Avengers endgame smart Hulk
explained his fusion with some vague
Mushmouth in about spending 18 months in
the gamma lab I put the brains in the
big and now and it's never really been
consistent whether Banner does or
doesn't retain memories when he's in
Hulk form Hulk is supposed to get
angrier and angrier and never lose a
fight yet danos knocked him out cold
his thunderclap is powerful enough to
extinguish jet fuel fire but not blow
the skin off Betty Ross's bones yeah
when it comes to his in that Ed Norton
Hulk film that many of us forget was
even part of the MCU Banner does cut
himself and bleeds into open bottles in
a factory bottles that later make people
ill with Vig gamma sickness one of them
was Stanley
but while digestion of his blood may
have been bad it sounds like
transfusions into the bloodstream we'll
be okay
more than okay this would actually be
consistent with the Planet Hulk comic
storyline in which Hulk's blood has
healing powers which he uses on the
people it's a car but considering we
have seen Planet Hulk adapted for thor
ragnarok
it's the storyline that follows Planet
Hulk that I think could inspire what we
will see next from Hulk in the MCU
assuming he does return in she-hulk but
before I continue thank you to the
sponsor of this video NZ makers of the
game crystal born forget everything you
know about mobile games folks crystal
borne its most impressive RPG game
that's on your phone if it's not on your
phone yet it should be crystal board is
available on Android and iOS with
crystal born you can fight unique bosses
collect exclusive heroes and play with
your friends from around the world with
fully animated attacks and stunning
visual effects and breathtaking arenas
and the best part it is totally free to
download use my link below to download
crystal burn yourself crystal Bourn is a
featured top new game on the Apple App
Store my favorite character lately has
been this big shirtless dude his name's
Maximoff in a game with lots of magic
swords and insane special powers all of
that Maximoff just straight-up gets in
people's faces and I've pre-cut some
after playing the game for a while I've
been able to level them up and boost his
armor so now those uppercuts are extra
nasty Maximoff and some of the other
epic level characters i've been able to
summon do battle on my behalf to win
campaigns and in the player versus
player mode I keep tweaking my team
while earning rewards here's my link
below to download crystal born yourself
and thanks again to NZ for sponsoring
this video
so if she Hulk is going to keep Bruce
Banner in the MCU as the donor of the
gamma-irradiated blood that gives her
her powers this makes Hulk blood a lot
more valuable to this universe because
now theoretically anyone could be Hulka
fide with a similar transfusion that
would correspond neatly to the storyline
that follows Planet Hulk world war Hawks
nutso crossover event that features Hulk
a fight versions of 7
Marvel heroes cap spider-man Wolverine
Thor Deadpool in World War Hulk's Red
Hulk is really the key player he's
revealed to be Thunderbolt Ross Ross
used aim in the intelligencia to
transform himself into Red Hulk in order
to fight Hulk as Red Hulk it's angrier
he emits heat making himself vulnerable
to overheating Red Hulk in general is
just really more aggressive he kills
abomination he destroys the Helicarrier
he causes an earthquake in San Francisco
and while all this stuff sounds crazy
the current MCU is becoming increasingly
set up for a Red Hulk world war Hulk's
event Thunderbolt Ross is still around
in this universe Marvel keeps bringing
him back in Civil War infinity wars
Starks funeral and in game and now in
Black Widow now I have speculated that
Ross could be involved in a thunderbolt
plot in the Falcon the Winter Soldier
but perhaps that could end with Ross
driven to experiment on himself using
gamma-irradiated blood that apparently
could be plugged into anyone according
to she-hulk series and set photos for
the fact in the Winter Soldier have also
shown Samson construction signs
rebuilding the world after the snap
Samson could be a nod to doc Samson
plays a pretty big role in the world war
Hulk's to vent and the character Simpson
was played by Ty Burrell in that first
Hulk film and before you say the Marvel
Studios will never adapt these Hulk
titles because the film rights are owned
by a separate rival studio Universal
cool those Jets now sure in the past
those shared rights by rival Studios
extended to characters related to the
main title so like for example Sony owns
the rights to spider-man which also by
extension gives them rights to
spider-man related characters like venom
and Morbius and when Foxx was a separate
studio it owned the rights to the x-men
and Fantastic Four but also by extension
had Deadpool who's a mutant and ego the
Libyan planet who was considered the
Fantastic Four villain but through a
special deal of IP swapping Marvel was
able to get special permission to use
them in the guardians of the galaxy vol
2 but with all this in mind the fact
that Disney Plus is doing HD Hulk's
series signals that universals ownership
of the whole world isn't as ironclad as
we thought now maybe the legal wording
is looser when it comes to streaming
series as opposed to theatrical releases
and legal legal Jen Walters found a
loophole or maybe since she Hulk was
once a member of the Fantastic Four
box could have had a stronger claim to
the character now Disney owns a box
properties or maybe universals rights
expired
whatever the reason rumor has it that
Marvel execs aren't
worried about the Hulk rights anymore
and Mark Ruffalo has been meeting with
Peggy about future solo films really
with rep lo squeeze and back in that
mokey in Detroit pursing Hulk his is now
closer to streaming down all the MCS
beans comment down below with your
thoughts on this and for our deeper
unfiltered Marvel theories join our
official discord server by becoming a
patron of new rock starts today at
patreon.com slash new rock stars follow
me on instagram and twitter at EA vas
followed new rock stars and subscribe to
new rock stars here and you tuber
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]